despite a jury in chicago convicting
actor jesse smallette of lying to police
about faking a hate crime black lives
matter is backing the now proven con man
saying that regardless of the jury's
decision the nation was founded on
racism meaning that the nation's systems
are so racist so the justice system's
rulings are racist the new york post
editorial board making the case that
blm's view of smallet tria of his trial
explains why critical race theory in
schools has so many parents in an uproar
let's bring in chris ruffo senior fellow
at the manhattan institute and a
contributing editor for city journal
chris welcome
it's great to be with you
so let's dig deeper on the new york post
take on this whole matter
it writes hannah jones argues that our
nation was born out of slavery rather
than the continental congress that the
declaration of independence was written
and a revolution fought primarily in
defense of slavery neither is true nor
is the idea that modern policing has its
roots in slave patrols or that
capitalism is inherently racist but as
with the defense of smilet the facts
don't matter he's a black man so he must
be innocent the system cannot be trusted
chris your thoughts
yeah that phrase uh facts don't matter
is really at the heart of what we're
talking about a critical race theory for
the last 30 years has argued that there
is no such thing as objective truth
they've argued that ideas like
rationality evidence empirical uh
data are merely figments of white
supremacy and so if there is no truth
there is no objectivity there are no
facts there's only subjective feelings
and even though jesse smollett obviously
all the evidence suggests that he
orchestrated a hate crime hoax his
feeling of being oppressed of being uh
of being attacked overrides any factual
or objective evidence and so the whole
world simply becomes their perception
they believe in their heart that white
supremacy is the dominant feature it
must be destroyed and they're willing to
do or say whatever it is no matter what
the facts in order to achieve it after
doing a lot of reporting on what's been
going on in our schools in recent months
i've talked to a lot of parents who say
look there are parts of american history
that aren't pretty we should teach
children that but teaching children to
see race and everything is what really
troubles them your thoughts
that's right i mean school should
absolutely present the entire honest
history of the united states including
the history of racial injustice but what
critical race theory does is it uses
those historical injustices as the
premise for telling individual students
children that they are guilty that they
are oppressed uh they're they're
oppressed or oppressors and that they
should be held responsible collectively
for historical crimes
this is not only anti-evidence it's
anti-american it's against the idea of
individual rights individual liberties
and individual expression
it should be removed from the classroom
it's pseudoscientific it hurts kids of
all racial backgrounds and we should get
back to teaching the facts teaching kids
how to be productive productive citizens
teaching the honest history in the
united states but always in the context
of our highest ideals and our steady
progress towards achieving them black
lives matter is now showing
unconditional support for smolette even
though he has been convicted calling the
trial a white supremacist charade does
that send a troubling message to our
children shouldn't they say basically we
were wrong and we apologize
they should but i think the message that
it sends to the public is that the black
lives matter organization although it's
built on a premise that we all agree
black lives do matter is a political
organization with a radical agenda it's
rooted in neo-marxist ideology it pushes
critical race theory-style conspiracy
theories to the public and this is just
another data point in the slow collapse
of black lives matter it had a high
point last year during the protests but
now americans have grown rightly
distrustful of an organization that
presented with the plain facts denies
them
this kind of ideology shouldn't be in
our courtroom and absolutely would no
doubt should not be in our schools this
conviction is obviously an embarrassment
that ruins jesse smallett's career
but what about undermining real victims
yeah of course i mean but what we've
seen we've seen a pattern a colleague of
mine will riley has written an entire
book called hate crime hoax these are
serious crimes but oftentimes in many
many cases they're actually hoaxes to
perpetuate a political narrative so we
should always approach these hate crimes
with a degree of skepticism we should
investigate them if they actually are
real crimes but we should not be
surprised that incidents like the jesse
smallett incident where they're simply
invented to promote a political
narrative
even though they end up hurting real
victims chris ruffo manhattan institute
senior fellow thanks so much for your
time have a great day
thank you
i'm steve doocy i'm brian killman and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis